[Musica]
bene oggi vi racconto alcune storie sono
storie che ho raccolto nell'ultimo
diciamo nel 2020 nel corso di 2020 in
diverse parti d'italia e sono storie di
come il clima sta cambiando l'italia
prima abbiamo sentito di come noi stiamo
cambiando il clima ma a sua volta il
clima ha degli effetti sul sul nostro
paese e sono effetti dio ho provato a
documentare ho provato a documentare
andando in giro per l'italia e
intervistando tanti italiani che in
questo momento sono testimoni di questi
di questi cambiamenti e quindi come si
diceva sono storie di pezzi del nostro
paese ma sono storie delle persone che
vivono e da cui ho tratto un libro e
alcuni brani di questo libro rivedrete
riprodotti oggi la prima storia sono
partito
dall'angolo più a nord ovest del nostro
paese che anche la montagna più alta
d'europa il monte bianco
qui si sono svolte ovviamente moltissime
vicende dell'alpinismo qui forse è nata
anche la storia dell'alpinismo
dell'alpinismo internazionale
ma qui vivono anche e lavorano delle
persone molto speciali che fanno
dell'alta montagna il loro mestiere un
mestiere molto difficile anche molto
pericoloso ma molto prestigioso se
vogliamo molto molto coraggioso e
comincio questa storia con un
personaggio che realtà non viene dal
monte bianco e walter bonatti walter
bonatti era
valtellinese ed è stato il membro più
giovane della spedizione che ha
conquistato il k2 la montagna degli
italiani la seconda cima più alta del
mondo nel 1954 quando torna viene
accusato di aver ostacolato la salita
dei due che erano stati prescelti per
andare in cima
non era vero ma lui ovviamente si
ritrova in una condizione quasi di
reietto no nell'alpinismo e quindi per
un anno non fa quasi niente poi nel 1955
decide di scalare le gag sul monte
bianco appunto che era considerata fino
a quel momento una impossibilità
dell'alpinismo ci riesce e quindi
diventa un'icona dell'alpinismo mondiale
facciamo 50 anni avanti e nel 2005 leghi
crolla con l'anno 270 mila metri cubi di
roccia la vedete nella parte chiara di
quella di quella fotografia e quando
studiano il perché questa montagna è
crollata riconoscono che il cambiamento
il riscaldamento climatico è stata una
delle cause principali che provocando lo
scioglimento del permafrost ha reso
possibile questo enorme crollo e i
crolli non sono una cosa rara
i crolli in alta montagna stanno
diventando estremamente frequenti e
rendono la vita di chi lavora in
montagna soprattutto delle guide alpine
estremamente più difficile e più
pericolosa normalmente si parla sempre
dello scioglimento dei ghiacciai ma i
crolli di roccia stanno diventando
effettivamente uno dei problemi più
importanti delle alte montagne e quindi
le le guide alpine
ci dicono un po queste queste cose le
guide alpine sono lì che osservano la
montagna che cambia e pensate che delle
100 più bella escursione le ascensioni
al monte bianco che sono state descritte
nel 75 da gaston rebuffat uno dei più
grandi alpinisti di tutti i tempi
oggi appoggi solamente due non hanno
subito effetti del cambiamento climatico
tre sono scomparse completamente e altre
si sono modificate in modo in modo
radicale questo ci dicono le guide le
guide alpine nostri concittadini che
vivono in montagna
se passiamo dall'altra parte delle alpi
troviamo le dolomiti le dolomiti da una
bellezza straordinaria sono diventate
patrimonio
dell'umanità è nelle dolomiti ci sono
delle comunità antichissime che si
occupano di mantenere questo paesaggio
straordinario particolare lavorano sulle
foreste una delle più antiche e la
magnifica comunità di fiemme che pensate
è stata fondata nel 1111 ed è ancora lì
che si occupa delle foreste della val di
fiemme
e in queste
in queste foreste
ci sono degli alberi molto particolari
sono degli alberi che suonano sono i
cosiddetti tronchi da risonanza sono
degli abeti un po come gli altri ma che
crescono in condizioni particolari e si
dice che antonio stradivari
andasse di persona a cercare i tronchi
migliori per costruire i suoi violini
sicuramente ancora oggi i liutai
d'italia ma di mezza europa si
riforniscono nelle foreste di paneveggio
ad esempio del legno di risonanza che
poi usano per fare questi strumenti
tra il
27 e il 29 di ottobre del 2018
però queste foreste hanno subito la
distruzione più grave che sia mai
capitata a memoria storica grazie a una
tempesta la tempesta vai a la tempesta
vaia stata un ciclone extratropicale di
cui ogni tanto ne arriva qualcuno
attraverso l'europa ma questa ha colpito
in particolare il sud il sud delle alpi
si calcola che siano stati abbattuti
quasi 8 milioni di alberi in un paio di
giorni sostanzialmente tra questi anche
migliaia di
alberi dei violini migliaia di tronchi
da risonanza sono andati sono andati
perduti in climatologi che diranno che
non è possibile attribuire un singolo
evento ai cambiamenti climatici ma vi
diranno anche che la frequenza e
l'intensità di eventi come vai a è
destinata ad aumentare grazie al
riscaldamento globale
e quindi anche qui ci sono dei
protagonisti come fabio che vivono e
lavorano in queste terre e si sono
trovati di fronte a questo panorama di
distruzione e hanno reagito come vedete
come vedete qui
però si sono anche chiesti come fare per
superare questo momento quindi ad
esempio fabio ogni beni ha organizzato
un crowd funding con il cuore riuscito a
raccogliere i tronchi da risonanza e
quindi a evitare che finissero
per essere distrutti dai parassiti nelle
foreste
però sicuramente è stato un evento molto
molto traumatico per lui e anche per le
altre persone che vivono nella valle
ovviamente
cambia lo scenario che abbiamo paesaggio
italia circondata dal mare voi siete
fortunati abitate abitate vicino vicino
al mare e anche il mare si sta
riscaldando le acque superficiali
mediterraneo sono aumentate di
temperatura di quasi un grado zero 89
per essere per essere precisi
e sembra poco sembra poco ma questo
cambiamento è già in grado di provocare
effetti molto importanti sulla fauna e
sulla flora effetti come questo
la moria dei coralli lavori e dei
coralli a delle gorgonie che negli
ultimi 10 12 anni ha interessato un po
tutta l'italia e oggi abbiamo in alcuni
parti del nostro paese perso 10 15 metri
di profondità cioè i coralli nelle acque
più superficiali sono morti per una
combinazione di temperature troppo alte
che però gli hanno affamati perché sono
cambiate le correnti e quindi il cibo
non aveva più e sono arrivati anche dai
parassiti
oppure effetti come questo
su una specie la pinna nobilis che il
più grande mollusco del mediterraneo
possono diventare altre quasi quasi un
metro a formano delle città che danno
anche ospitalità a tutta una serie di
altre specie animali
bene anche qui a causa di alcuni
parassiti che sono arrivati grazie ai
cambiamenti climatici
lepine 9 sono quasi completamente
scomparse e per mesi si sono trovati i
gusci sulle spiagge in varie parti
d'italia questa è un'immagine che viene
da trieste qui avete un'altra
testimonianza
di chi aveva scritto un libro
utilizzando appunto facendo delle foto a
questi a questi organismi
ovviamente questo degli effetti sulla
pesca
sono stato a parlare lungamente al
mercato ittico di chioggia con i
pescatori e al mercato ittico di pioggia
arrivano le imbarcazioni che pescano
raccolgono i molluschi nell'adriatico
l'adriatico è uno dei tre motori freddi
del mediterraneo quindi gli effetti che
siano lì non sono solo locali ma
l'adriatico contribuisce al
rimescolamento delle acque di tutto il
mediterraneo ed è il motore dei tre
motori freddi del mediterraneo quello
che si sta rallentando più velocemente e
quindi pescatori anche loro reagiscono e
interessante vedere il parallelismo tra
le parole di norge tiozzo e quella di
giorgio passino guida del monte bianco
c'è questo senso di frustrazione non c'è
questo senso di cambiamento che non si
può controllare e che sta impattando
pesantemente la loro vita
ma l'italia è anche
il primo produttore di vino del mondo
è un settore che vale dipende
dall'annata insomma 12 13 15 miliardi
l'anno e il vino cambia la coltivazione
della vite ovviamente influenza
moltissimo il paesaggio in tante regioni
italiane anche anche nella vostra
se oggi parlate con un viticoltore vi
dirà come negli ultimi 15 20 anni
coltivare il vino arrivare dalla vigna
alla bottiglia sia diventato sempre più
sempre più difficile perché gli eventi
estremi le gelate tardive le grandinate
le piogge la siccità richiedono degli
investimenti sempre più grossi per
portare a termine la vendemmia e portare
alla produzione alla produzione di vino
non solo ma in alcuni casi il
il cambiamento è tale per cui in alcune
regioni si stima che già fra 20 30 anni
non sarà possibile
coltivare le stesse vigne che si stanno
coltivando adesso anche in regioni
importanti come quella del barolo e
quindi anche qui i viticoltori come ivo
nardi portano la loro testimonianza una
testimonianza di un impatto forte anche
un impatto forte dal punto di vista
emotivo
e chiaro che quello che abbiamo
cominciato a vedere tutti però di più
negli ultimi anni e questo cambiamento
dell'intensità e della frequenza degli
eventi estremi questo è
adriatico questa è una città della costa
dell'adriatico e vedete appunto piccoli
tornado che si formano nuvolosità
inquietante quasi è effettivamente il la
frequenza e l'intensità di eventi
estremi è aumentata e così devo dire
quello che una volta si diceva al brno
non c'è più il tempo di una volta ma era
una chiacchiera che si facevano c'è ma
non c'è più il tempo di una volta beh
adesso lo dicono quello era un po
diciamo uno sbaglio di percezione che
molti di noi facevano ma oggi abbiamo
climatologi meteorologiche ci dicono le
stesse cose che ci dicono che
effettivamente
il clima sta diventando dominato dai
venti estremi molto brevi a cui seguono
lunga siccità ma noi non siamo veramente
preparati per
vivere e portare avanti la nostra
attività in un clima di questo di questo
genere e quindi le persone più disparate
si trovano di fronte a eventi
catastrofici come in questo caso
una grandinata che ha distrutto
letteralmente io sono andato a vedere il
locale di marco b scalo ha distrutto i
tetti divelto le finestre non su questo
lato sull'altro lato 3 milioni e mezzo
di danni in due ore in una piccola zona
dicendo questo è solo uno dei casi che
si sono che si sono registrati è di
nuovo
spesso si parla di queste cose in
termini quantitativi no todt milioni di
danni todt edifici ma c'è l'impatto
emotivo sulle persone come la mamma di
anna che hanno subito un tornado che ha
devastato la loro casa e che oggi
qualunque rumore un po intenso fa
reagire in maniera molto molto
importante
e io potrei raccontarvi molte altre
storie ne ho raccolte veramente tante e
l'ho fatto proprio per spiegare agli
italiani nel modo più chiaro possibile
che cambiando climatico non è un
qualcosa che riguarda gli orsi polari o
le savane o le foreste e qui e ora sta
già avendo degli effetti molto
importanti e anche un'altra cosa
importante che in questo cambiamento
purtroppo non si fermerà a breve anche
se noi smettiamo di emettere domani c'è
un ritardo perché la co2 rimane
nell'atmosfera per un centinaio di anni
e quindi quello che noi dobbiamo e
possiamo fare oggi
è limitare i danni e agire perché non si
vada incontro agli effetti più gravi dei
cambiamenti climatici che potrebbero
rendere anche alcune parti del nostro
pianeta
difficilmente abitabili e per questo
bisogna come è stato detto anche prima
riprendere in mano il senso della
responsabilità ci sono pochi leader nel
campo soprattutto culturale ma nella
politica anche ci sono poche persone
famose che si espongono a parlare di
queste cose il angelo pistoletto è uno
dei grandi artisti del nostro paese l'ha
fatto
ho avuto la fortuna di parlargli ma c'è
bisogno di molte più persone che
prendano questo tema sul serio e che lo
trattino veramente come una crisi non
come un qualcosa di passeggero ci vuole
ci vuole molto impegno bisogna anche
capire
un altro aspetto cioè che le
responsabilità
della crisi climatica non sono
ugualmente distribuite
non tutte le persone su questo pianeta
contribuiscono allo stesso modo
pensate che il 10 per cento più ricco
del pianeta e mette più del 50 per cento
delle emissioni di gas a effetto serra
il 10 per cento più povero emette circa
il 4 per cento
quindi quando noi chiediamo ai paesi
poveri di fare delle cose dovremmo
sempre tenere a mente questo numero e sa
perché noi facciamo parte di questo 10
per cento e che quindi la nostra
responsabilità è più grande nel prendere
delle contromisure
per risolvere la crisi climatica
c'è bisogno quindi di parlare anche
della giustizia sociale
bisogna prendere in mano
contemporaneamente il tema della
giustizia ambientale e il tema giustizia
sociale altrimenti correremo solo dei
super ricchi che cercheranno di farci
scappare tutti su marte come qualcuno
già sta proponendo di fare
e qui ci sono molti giovani per fortuna
i giovani ci hanno ricordato tutto
questo in maniera molto molto netta
molto precisa lo ricordano tutti i
giorni alla politica e
chiedono di ascoltare la scienza è già
stato detto qui oggi bisogna ascoltare
veramente la scienza la scienza è stata
inascoltata per questo per oltre 40 anni
primi stata ignorata poi si è detto che
non avevano ragione
adesso finalmente siamo arrivati a un
punto nel quale ci si crede è però
bisogna agire e bisogna agire
di conseguenza
c'è anche come dire un rischio ulteriore
che è quello che la gente cominci a dire
beh ma adesso è troppo tardi
e non possiamo fare più niente ma
guardate non è così non è così prima
quelli che dici quelli che prima
dicevano sì vabbè ma non è un grosso
problema adesso tendono a dire beh ma è
troppo tardi
in realtà non è troppo tardi diventa ci
sono tantissime cose che possiamo fare e
questa mattina e ne abbiamo sentite
molte questa mattina abbiamo sentito la
testimonianza di persone che hanno
deciso di cambiare la loro vita per
contribuire positivamente a risolvere
questo problema e quindi quello che vi
dico è che c'è bisogno di responsabilità
c'è bisogno di prendere in mano il
problema c'è bisogno di gestirlo c'è
bisogno la collaborazione di tutti noi
possiamo fare la differenza
dobbiamo fare la differenza su questo ma
dobbiamo renderci conto che l'azione
personale deve essere anche un'azione
pubblica deve essere anche un'azione
politica deve essere un'azione a tutto
tondo e quindi io vi invito se diciamo
le cose che avete sentito da me ma anche
da altri
questa mattina in qualche modo vi hanno
mi hanno colpito veramente a fare
qualcosa perché chi ha capito e non fa
niente in realtà non ha capito niente
grazie
[Applauso]